So, we just learned about what was
probably the most important piece of
math for this class,
in statistics, called Bayes Rule.
It's invented by Reverend Thomas Bayes,
who was a British mathematician,
and a Presbyterian minister
the eighteenth century.
Bayes Rule is usually stated as follows.
P of A given B, where B is the evidence
and is variable we care about,
is P of B given A times
P of A over P of B.
This expression is is
called the likelihood.
This is called the prior.
In this is called
the marginal likelihood.
The expression over here
is called the posterior.
The interesting thing is the way
the probabilities are reverted.
Say we have evidence B.
We know about B but
we really care about the variable A.
So, example B is a test result.
We don't care about
the test result as much we
care about the effect of
whether we have cancer or not.
This diagnostic reasoning which
is from evidence to its causes,
is turned upside down by Bayes Rule
into a cause of reasoning.
Which is given, hypothetically,
we knew the cause,
what would be the probability of
the evidence which just observed?
But to correct for this inversion,
we have to multiply by the prior
of the cause to be the case in the first
place, in this case having cancer or
not, and divide it by
the probability of the evidence.
P of B.
Which often is expanded using
the theorem of tolerability as follows:
The probability of B is the sum of all
probabilities of B conditional of A,
lower caps a, times the probability
of A equals lower caps a.
This is total probability.
[INAUDIBLE]